wouldn't you know a little birdie told
us it's world wildlife day
tomorrow and that little birdie of
course rocky diaz
she joins us from the henderson bird
viewing preserve with how we can take a
walk on the wild side here in vegas hey
rocky
hey kirsten yeah so i'm so glad you guys
told that story because lisa here was
just telling me about
ebird.com right yeah and you guys use
that here at the preserve we do you can
go on ebert and if you put in henderson
bird viewing preserve
uh you'll see that birders have put what
birds they've seen here today so you
know what to expect when you come out
wow okay so we'll get to the you know
how to properly bird here
at the henderson spot but first i want
to know about this land look at this
vast beautiful land where are we right
now and how did this come about
so the henderson bird viewing preserve
actually sits on the water reclamation
facility's property it's over 100 acres
and there's nine evaporation ponds
that the water reclamation facility uses
and uh it kind of started back in the
70s with the ponds here the birds
naturally came as a place to
uh live or rest on their migratory
travels
and where there's birds there's going to
be birders right
eventually the audubon society's
christmas bird count
added this spot to their annual bird
count
and in 1998 we opened up the henderson
bird viewing preserve to the public
that is amazing and you've told me
before too that nevada is among the most
diverse
birds in the world yeah so you can see
over 200 species of birds
here at the bird viewing preserve
throughout the year and nevada in
general
sees even more than that different
varieties of birds wow that's so cool
and i i mean
honestly i'm a rookie here this is my
first time bird viewing and it's so much
fun it's also a really peaceful activity
safe activity you can do
during this time and i'm wondering you
know i've heard a lot of different
sounds
walking through here is there a certain
bird call that you would do to try to
attract them over
how does that work so instead of a bird
call you're probably going to need a lot
of patience to sit down and wait for the
birds to come to you but some
professional birders do use bird calls
to identify the birds instead of through
their physical features
interesting okay well i do i also want
to let you guys know obviously like we
mentioned earlier
world wildlife day is tomorrow and in
vegas you don't think
you know there's a lot of wildlife here
but there is it's the henderson bird
viewing preserve here
and then we have the lions habitat ranch
we have
camel safari there's camels in the
valley did you know that i didn't know
that
see you got to celebrate tomorrow and
beyond so thank you guys i'm ready to go
you know see more you but i feel like
i'm missing a few tools
yeah so we're going to want to remember
to bring our binoculars wait don't tell
everybody yet we're going to tell you
what you need
to properly bird watch coming up later
in the show
i'll send it back to you all right rocky
the next step we'll have coming up later